ryan leaf andre ware
brian bosworth purvis
ellison think about these names
do you know them a lot of you don't
these are guys that were drafted very
high
in sports very very high sam bowie
drafted before michael jordan can we get
over the point of people thinking that
talent is enough like even content
which is the most powerful thing which
is you know if you have talent you can
pump it out
this whole notion in business that you
know
you can't out hustle or outwork somebody
to be better than them
is insanity anybody that follows sports
and
especially if they follow drafts in any
way
at all achilles smith did i mention him
already i mean
seriously anybody who follows sports and
drafts in any shape or form
that doesn't understand that i don't
give a rat's ass if you're a better
writer
or if you can pump out better videos
that if you're not willing to out work
and love it have a passion for it then
you're gonna get beat
by someone who's not as good and
absolutely doesn't have the talent that
you have but it's going to make a whole
lot more money
have a whole lot more opportunity i
think the line in the sand
the defining thing in this whole game is
hustle and i wanted to pinch you that
picture because i know a lot of you know
those athletes
i want you to understand jeff george
anybody i want you to understand okay i
don't care
i want people to understand that
somebody's gonna outwork you i'm
definitely gonna outwork you
and there's other people that are gonna
outwork you in your niche and if you
don't start putting in the hours
and start dropping if you don't start
dropping the xbox controller
and the repaddle and your tivo remote
and that beer after work in your hands
you're gonna lose
i don't give a rat's ass if you want to
yale or you're the most creative
son of a baby you know i'm trying to fix
the cursing with misha i love you
if you're the biggest you know best of
all time but you don't put in the work
in the hustle
you're gonna get beat and businesses
that don't care
and have little small startups that care
more they're going to beat you too
and so big confusion in our space
especially amongst a lot of bloggers
and a lot of web sites they think that
they have better design and better
functionality and they think they're
going to win
you're not